bonjour aujourd'hui 23 octobre bienvenue
pour cette nouvelle édition de votre
journal du vendredi sur téléphiles au
sommaire aujourd'hui le club de football
de trappes qui se lance dans le soutien
scolaire reportage auprès de l'étoile
sportive qui propose aux enfants de
réelles de délaisser les crampons pour
réviser leurs leçons nous parlerons
aussi le politique avec philippe
chevrier candidat sur la liste du front
national en ile-de-france derrière
valeron de saint-just et tête de liste
dans les yvelines
c'est l'invité de cette édition et puis
comme chaque fin de semaine l'essentiel
de l'actualité depuis lundi des grèves
dans les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines conflit
également autour de la réorganisation
des pmi dans le département et en fin
d'émission les enfants aussi auront la
parole sur l'actualité c'est une
nouvelle séquence à découvrir dans le
journal là mais l'actualité du jour tout
d'abord c'est au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines où se tenait
un job dating cette entreprise était
présente sur cet événement organisé par
le groupe option les candidats au nombre
de 40 était présélectionné par les
organisateurs en fonction de leurs
compétences et des postes à pourvoir
c'est un événement job dating que nous
faisons pour tous les clients du groupe
option pour les aider sur leur
prestation de recrutement sur tous les
postes à pourvoir en cdi sur toute l'île
de france
on n'est pas sur un forum emploi ou les
candidats arrivent avec des cv
uniquement là ils ont été vus en
présélection téléphonique avant ils ont
eu un entretien en contrôle de référence
et puis une vérification de tous les
documents et papiers pour être
sélectionnés au niveau des rendez vous
j'avais quelques difficultés difficultés
à recruter sur sur ces profils
donc là ce que ça représente ça nous
fait un gain de temps le fait est que
les profils que gvg là aujourd'hui je
les ai pas trouvé mon côté donc c'est
qu'elle a eu à utiliser d'autres voies
de diffusion certainement et donc c'est
ça qui est intéressant aujourd'hui
l'invité fil rouge de ce vendredi c'est
donc philippe chevrier le responsable du
front national dans les yvelines est
tête de liste ile de france bleu marine
dans le département pour les régionales
de décembre bonjour et bienvenue sur ce
plateau on vient de parler un instant
d'un forum de l'emploi sur saint quentin
en yvelines ce qui peut nous amener
directement à parler de vos propositions
dans le domaine on peut citer puisque
c'est dans le programme de votre
candidat la tête de liste aux régionales
cette fois ci va le rendre saint-just la
mise en place d'un dispositif de
sauvegarde de l'activité et de l'emploi
avec un nouvel organisme qui serait créé
lot 1 re es eux ça consisterait en quoi
ça consisterait à reprendre les
entreprises qui sont en difficulté pour
un euro symbolique évidemment et
examiner si elles sont encore
exploitables ou si il n'y a plus rien à
faire
bon c'est une manière si vous voulez qui
permet de sauver un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui pourraient l'être
alors évidemment derrière il y aurait la
banque régionale d'investissement qui
pourraient éventuellement recapitaliser
cette entreprise après une éventuelle
restructuration ou réorientation de son
activité
r ça c'est une des propositions autour
de l'emploi il ya d'autres axes qui
peuvent être développés pour aider ces
entreprises qui sont en difficulté et
qui recrutent difficilement aujourd'hui
par exemple dans le cadre des appels
d'offres qui sont faits par la région il
est évident que on privilégiera plus
particulièrement les pme et pmi de la
région ile de france sas est une c'est
une tendance assez lourde du front
national ou au que ce soit privilégiée
au sein de chacune des régions en se
disant absolument rien voilà donc il ya
ont pris les joueurs
jiras également les commerces de
proximité
ça c'était aussi quelque chose auquel on
tient beaucoup et par ce biais en espère
sauvegarder tout ce qu'on pourra
sauvegarder comme emplois dans l'île de
france étant entendu que évidemment
l'île de france fait partie de la france
et que évidemment il ya des problèmes
qui nous déclarations ne sont pas prises
par les régions effective fille pure il
vous restait en plateau on va continuer
ce journal avec cette fois ci un
reportage consacré au soutien scolaire
les vacances c'est un moment de repos
pour la plupart des enfants c'est aussi
un moment pour mettre à profit les
révisions pour revoir certaines notions
scolaire l'étoile sportive c'est le club
de football de trappes a décidé
d'apporter sa pierre à l'édifice le
renforce
comment forcément scolaire pardon que le
club proposera ensuite se prolonger tout
au long de l année le reportage de
mélanie poker et si dans le football il
était aussi question de mathématiques et
de français
c'est le pari de l'étoile sportive le
club de football de trappes 32 enfants
de 9 à 10 ans issus du club
approfondissent chaque jour ces notions
scolaire en n'oubliant jamais leur
passion le football
on s'arrête plus à ce qu'ils ne savent
pas plutôt parce qu'ils savent et
et on revient tous les jours par dessus
à chaque fois jusqu'à qui connaît ce b
très bien leurs tables de multiplication
par et pour la géométrie les français
avec un éducateur pour quatre enfants se
renforce colère se fait sur une durée
d'une heure si l'encadrement ne veux pas
parler de soutien scolaire à proprement
dit c'est l'importance de l'école qui
est aussi enseigner à ces jeunes
trappistes
voilà j'ai cette sensibilité vis-à-vis
d'eux ayant même temps cette
connaissance où j'ai le sentiment que
parfois quand ils sont très bons au foot
ils se disent l'école c'est pas grave et
c'est justement à eux que je m'adressais
c'est qu'ils sont très bons en foot
c'est juste que ça passera par l'école
aussi ce renfort mais maintenu tout au
long de l'année des bus récupère les
enfants à la sortie des classes
histoire de faire encore travailler ses
méninges avant de chausser ses crampons
je reviens vers vous philippe chevrier
il était question du soutien scolaire
d'éducation dans le programme du front
national pour les régionales il est
aussi question de la formation des
jeunes plus particulièrement
l'apprentissage en le rendant possible
dès 14 ans oui absolument
vous avez tout à fait raison je pense
que c'est une des actions prioritaires
d'heuliez effectivement cet
apprentissage à l éducation normale est
de ne pas faire une séparation entre les
deux de faire de faire une espèce de
continuité entre la le l'éducation
normal on va dire et puis cet
apprentissage plus technique d'ailleurs
qu'autre chose car on a vraiment besoin
en france 2 de gens qui sont spécialisés
dans un certain nombre de techniques et
nous voudrions valoriser ces filières
d'excellence par le biais de cet
apprentissage devant là on a vu une
initiative qui était menée par un club
de sport le club de football de la ville
de trappes de soutien scolaire pour
aider les jeunes à réviser un petit peu
de sortir du sport c'est une bonne
initiative nous bien sûr tout ce qui va
dans le bon sens évidemment on prend il
n'y a aucun problème
je vous signale cancer aussi fait des
limites à l'éducation nationale parce
que là ce sont les clubs sportifs qui
organisent du soutien scolaire
oui alors c'est peut-être aussi un moyen
d'y intéresser les jeunes par un autre
biais mais bien sûr bien sûr tout ce qui
peut être ludique et amener les gens les
jeunes à une
alors une certaine formation et aucun
problème bien entendu je vous signale
quand même 4 ap
il ya des petits soucis puisque il ya
une conseillère municipale madame
breugnot qui va passer au front national
3 et aussi comment pourquoi c'est un
souci pour le non
pour la municipalité il ya quelque chose
qui ne s'est pas associée pour votre
formation petit le cadre du soutien
scolaire d'ailleurs on va s'arrêter sur
cette campagne des régionales à
proprement parler le front national qui
pourrait réaliser un score sans
précédent rappelons qu'aujourd'hui il
n'y a aucun des lions en ile-de-france
du front national on vous place
aujourd'hui en tant qu'arbitre entre le
ps et les républicains de votre score va
dépendre la victoire de la gauche ou de
la droite
comment vous analysez ces différents
sondages a écouté avec avec bonheur mais
ce qui se passe c'est que on devrait
déjà être l'assemblée régionale
parce que on a fait 9 3 si vous souvenez
le score de la delà du front national à
l'époque avait été nettement en embêter
par la présence d'une liste concurrente
qui l'avait empêché de passer la barre
des 10%
c'est ce qu'en dit cela étant dit
absolument cela étant dit on va réaliser
sans doute un score très important je
crois que on est crédité de 21 ans s'est
tué en sautant des 20% là voilà et puis
on voit bien que le score du front
national nationalement parlant ne cesse
d'augmenter donc j'espère bien également
qu'en ile de france ce sera eux ou se
trouve aujourd'hui vos réserves de voix
parce que certains vous disent en train
de chercher les électeurs plutôt chez
les communistes les créditer autour de
10 % d'autres vous oppose aussi à
nicolas dupont aignan où se trouvent les
réserves de voix aujourd'hui dont les
réserves de voix le chant suite tout le
monde en fait les gens s'aperçoivent que
nous avait dit à cette information qui
vous gênent plus ou moins vous avez
évoqué le dernier scrutin
les rôles sont bien sûr il ya des il ya
des formations qui sont plus proches de
nous que d'autres
bien entendu par certains aspects mais
ma part tous et donc évidemment si eux
ne passent pas la barre des 10% il est
évident qu'un certain nombre de leurs
électeurs vont passer au deuxième tour
sur le front national c'est évident mais
avant cela avant même le premier tour
notre campagne va toucher tout le monde
parce que effectivement les gens sont
déçus à la fois par les socialistes à la
fois par ce qui s'appelle les
républicains aujourd'hui
vous débauchez justement ces élus
républicains vous venez de l'évoquer
avec le cas de trappes
comment vous expliquez ce rapprochement
comment s'opère ce rapprochement entre
son élection c'est un carte des anciens
élus des républicains qui se voir et
sont déçus ils sont déçus ils espéraient
quelque chose avec sarkozy et puis n'ont
rien vu et puis avec les les nouveaux
problèmes que rencontre cette
organisation des républicains cette
lutte intestine avec une dizaine de
candidats sur la ligne de départ
ça les décourage on veut emmener dans le
cadre des primaires parce que ceci dit
des divisions des tensions il y en a eu
aussi au front national récemment c'est
vrai on vous dit qu'on est dans le cadre
des primaires c'est vrai et que il
s'agit d'une élection régionale mais les
gens ont très bien compris que au
travers de l'élection régionale ce qui
se jouait c'était un marchepied vers
l'élection présidentielle qui est dans
18 mois en fait donc voilà c'est les
gens mélangent tout mais c'est aussi un
peu le cas pour le front national parce
que ça permet aussi de tester la
capacité à rassembler quelle que soit la
région et puis d'ailleurs marine le pen
aussi qui sera candidate en 2017 va
aussi pouvoir utiliser ce scrutin pour
asseoir sa légitimité
tout à fait c'est bien que soit la
formation politique et c'est bien le but
donc les deux scrutins sont conviés
quelle que soit la fonction c'est ce que
je vous disais les deux scrutins sont
bien liés et les gens l'ont bien compris
et c'est pour ça que au travers
l'élection régionale il pose des
questions aussi qui ont trait au
national pour être sûr que tout ça soit
cohérent non justement puisqu'on parle
du national un mot tout de même sur
l'événement médiatique d'hier soir
marine le pen qui annule sa venue sur le
plateau des paroles et des actes qui
n'acceptent pas les conditions qui sont
posées c'est une belle opération de
communication pour le front national
non c'est juste que si vous voulez quand
on est prévenus à minuit que les règles
du jeu vont changer pour une émission
qui est aussi importante que celle là il
ya quelque chose qui va pas par ailleurs
il faut les connaître ces règles c'est à
dire qu'on avait rajouté à une émission
qui est assez longue de deux heures je
suis bien placé pour savoir que dix
minutes c'est déjà difficile mais deux
heures c'est vraiment il faut vraiment
être une personne extraordinaire pour
arriver à supporter deux heures de débat
mais en plus on lui rajouter 30 minutes
avec un débat régional donc sur d'autres
sujets et locaux etc
mais il était bien normal à la dernière
minute à la dernière minute un premier
temps marine le pen a dit oui après elle
a dit non non non les mots ont été d'une
violence aussi rond on va conclure sur
ça parce que ça concerne par la région
directement mais il était question dans
le communiqué de la présidente du front
national de l'amateurisme de la
servilité de david pujadas
le front national qui attaquent les
médias qui a taclé une fois mais elle
sait sont 100 millions l'agréable
exprimer bon ça comme il s'en sortir
vous disiez elle a dit oui dans un
premier temps ne l'a jamais dit oui elle
a dit que l'irs est éventuellement si on
remplaçait le débat qui était prévu par
un débat régional qui est elle même une
ouverture importante parce qu'au dernier
moment
changez d'optique complètement pour
faire un débat régional
c'est quand même déjà quelque chose qui
va dans le sens de justement de
l'administration de france 2 bon eh
non ça a été refusé monsieur pujadas a
dit non ce sera comme ça ce sera 3
heures de débats bah non non c'est pas
possible donc là elle a dit non
effectivement on me l'a jamais dit oui
un jour non à la campagne en
ile-de-france sur la candidature de
valence injuste qu'elle trésorier du
front national j'ai relu plusieurs
articles qui lui était consacré
récemment il était présenté comme
l'inconnu du fn comme ayant un déficit
de notoriété
vous réagissez par rapport à ça va
d'abord il connaît déjà d'abord il est
plus connu que moi donc de 6 déjà un
point non c'est un peu exagéré
de toute façon c'est vrai que on peut
pas reprocher au front national de ne
pas avoir de cadrer à chaque fois qu'il
se présente dire qu'ils sont inconnus
c'est un peu facile
donc il est élu membre du bureau
exécutif
il est trésorier il a été conseiller
régional dans le nord pendant de longues
années il est aujourd'hui le patron de
la fédération de paris c'est une
personne qui est extrêmement légitime
pour se présenter aux régionales sur les
deux festivals handicap pour progresser
en termes de voix justement est dépassé
cette barre des 20% qu'on évoquait tout
n a non mais pour faire 40 % c'est un
handicap mais pour progresser au
contraire c'est un avantage parce que
plus vous partez de bas elle plus vous
voulez monter non je crois que
effectivement il va monter il est
extrêmement dynamique
il est sur les marchés en permanence il
est au contact des gens il vient sur
tous les plateaux à chaque fois quand il
est invité et je pense qu'il viendra
donc chez vous ces orientations
et donc voilà donc c'est sans doute le
meilleur candidat qu'on pouvait avoir
aujourd'hui en ile de france et il fait
une campagne formidable est extrêmement
dynamique et tous les militants
d'ailleurs sont à fond derrière lui et
en particulier dans les yvelines
malgré cette mise en examen alors cette
mise en examen elle repose sur quoi
c'est là qu'il a fait aussi parler de
lui il en a souri en disant enfin on
parle de moi oui oui c'est une manière
de le prendre et je crois que la raison
non
ça repose sur rien il s'agit de décompte
de de l'association jeanne qui nous
permettait de financer la les campagnes
de nos candidats jeanne à qui on a fait
appel à de nombreuses reprises la de
nombreuses élections tous les toutous ce
système tout ce process a été présenté à
la commission nationale des comptes
régulièrement à chaque élection la
commission nationale des comptes a donné
son feu vert
à chaque fois elle a d'ailleurs
remboursé normalement les candidats
chaque fois bon donc yaya je vois pas ce
qu'on peut reprocher c'est un jeu c'est
vraiment un procès sans entrer dans le
fond du dossier parce qu'il y aura une
procédure qui est en cours et donc on
n'est pas là pour juger ou non mais
c'est pas un handicap vous bottez en
touche je vous préfère ne pas en parler
on l'abordé le problème sinon non
lorsqu'on vous pose la question
lorsqu'il va la rencontre sur sur les
marchés par exemple est ce qu est ce qu
on vous en parlait ce que ça peut être
un handicap
en vérité pour vous dire vrai on n'en
parle pas les gens nous demandent de
rien là dessus ils sont pas très au fait
de ces affaires là mais s'il nous en
parle absolument aucun problème du
programme al parce que le temps passe et
il nous reste quelques minutes jouées
accord qu'on en vient au programme dans
ces cas-là tout à l'heure on a évoqué la
formation l'emploi quels sont vos axes
prioritaires pour la région déjà en cas
de victoire le plus urgent ce serait de
bloquer le grand paris ça fait partie de
vos propositions c'est d'abord
d'économiser de l'argent on mettrait de
côté de ces dans les premières pages du
programme que vous et lui visiblement
c'est de mettre de côté
240 millions bon déjà de côté alors 100
millions qu on rendrait aux franciliens
finalement et 140 millions conre et en
riant très vert
les nos priorités alors dans nos
priorités ont laissé économie de 240
millions sur un certain nombre de postes
c'est vous l'avez dans le programme je
pense que les gens d'ailleurs peuvent le
consulter sur le seul site internet
vidéo bleu marine donc qu'ils peuvent y
aller il ya aucun problème et y verront
le tableau qui indique exactement le
détail les économies de le détail des
économies là où on peut en faire quoi là
où il nous semble qu'il ya des gabegies
voilà alors soit une priorité
j'évoquais le grand paris total où ils
ont bloqué ce dans paris écoutez bloquer
le rang paris c'est peut-être pas comme
ça qu'il faut présenter les choses c'est
dire que cette cette volonté de vouloir
harmoniser ce qui se passe à la fois
dans la petite couronne et dans la ville
de paris ça peut très bien se faire au
niveau de la région
voilà c'est ça que nous pensons donc
c'est inutile pour nous de créer encore
un nouveau bidule avec encore des
fonctionnaires etc
derrière qui va coûter extrêmement
d'argent on voit bien comment ça se
passe l'intercommunalité par exemple
dans les ive et qui a créé une un
foisonnement de fonctionnaires dans
toutes ses six essais intercommunalités
et en même temps les communes n'ont pas
baissé leurs effectifs
donc on arrive à des situations
absolument catastrophique en une dizaine
d'années on a en a augmenté les les
impôts de 60% de même date même
d'ailleurs que les effectifs des envois
bien qu'il ya une une correspondance
très forte une corrélation très forte
entre les deux bon voila il donc les
autorités à avoir autour du transport il
ya un événement sur le transport soluble
dans le grand paris lire aussi le
transport absolument donc nous alors
c'est pas du tout le grand paris express
justement c'est cette affaire là qui
faisait partie du grand paris donc ses
deux boucles de
de relier passerait par 510 jusqu'à sa
claire ce qui coûte énormément d'argent
qui selon nous ne servirait qu'à rome
relier des endroits où il ya
relativement peu de population pour
l'instant qui serait sans doute de
nature à enrichir un certain nombre de
promoteurs immobiliers dans le futur
mais qui ne correspondrait pas aux
attentes actuelles des gens qui prennent
les transports en attente c'est de
renforcer les transports qui ont
renforcé ce qui existe qui existent les
gens très bien on est très précis
là-dessus donc un certain nombre de deux
propositions que nous faisons je vais
pas les détails et maintenant visionner
en une quinzaine mais voilà c'est ça a
c'est donc moderniser rendre les rames
automatiques ce qui permet d'ailleurs de
raccourcir les délais entre les rames et
donc en faire plus à offrir plus de
sièges qui soit plus confortable qu'ils
soient à l'heure qu'ils soient réguliers
ponctuelle du terrain enfin un rêve quoi
ça s'arrête là pour la partie du
programme on aura l'occasion bien
évidemment d'y revenir au cours de cette
campagne dans nos prochaines éditions du
journal ou encore du 7-8 politique
philippe chevrier vous restez encore en
plateau quelques instants comme chaque
vendredi on passe à l'essentiel de la
semaine
voici donc le zapping de l'info le
résumé de la semaine les principaux
sujets développés dans notre journal
chaque jour à 18h montage a signé xavier
jaglin distribution de tracts
d'information aux usagers
cette scène s'est répétée toute la
journée devant les huit médiathèque
saint-quentinoise devant celle de magny
les hameaux une trentaine de personnes
s'étaient rassemblées en ligne de mire
les problèmes d'effectifs du réseau des
médiathèques
on est moins pour les ouvertures on est
moins pour le service public on est
moins pour les médiations qu'est ce
qu'on va faire on va fermer sommes
aujourd'hui en rhdp demande de cinq
agents de par médiathèque aimé-césaire
et anatole france ainsi que leurs
responsables du débit aux bus donc les
choses sont en cours je peux pas aller
plus vite changer les comportements tout
en s'amusant c'est maintenant possible
avec virus war le jeu interactif lancé
par hachette prévention place les
participants à l'intérieur d'un être
humain
fonctionnant sur le principe de
lasergame les joueurs équipés de fusils
d'assaut ont pour mission de détruire le
virus du sida virus soir c'est
relativement simple les gens viennent on
va les miniaturiser on va les injecter
dans une personne qui est nouvellement
donc séropositives et ils vont pouvoir
essayer et tenté de tuer le virus du
sida à coups de pistolet laser et chaque
prix tiers de pistolet laser permet
effectivement donc d'avoir des tiers de
trithérapie j'espère vraiment que
que tous ceux qui ont des convictions de
gauche et des convictions écolos vont se
rendre compte du moment dans lequel on
est qu'il faut avancer ensemble il faut
travailler ensemble coquet peut-être que
tout n'est pas parfait qu'il ya des
choses il ya des déceptions n'est que
l'essentiel quand même élan et qu' il
faut pas oublier le front national ne
faut pas oublier la droite on a face à
nous une droite très dure vraiment très
dur donc nous ne l'oublions pas c'est
pmi on vise en fait de les optimiser
c'est à dire de permettre une ouverture
pas simplement quelques demi-journées
par semaine comme c'est actuellement le
cas
mais des ouvertures 5 jours sur 7
parfois même le samedi on vise aussi des
délais d'attentes pour les pour être
reçus qu'ils soient moins longues parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'actuellement il ya
à peu près des délais de deux mois et
demi pour avoir un rendez vous il y en
aura comme qu'une vingtaine qui vont
être conservées sur 60
même si elles sont verts plus longtemps
on imagine mal qu'un comment ça peut
être plus efficace alors ça peut être
plus efficace parce que ça veut dire
qu'en fait les équipes médicales seront
concentrées sur effectivement certains
centres de pmi à la journée donc déjà y
aura pas de perte de transport pour pour
les personnels de santé dans les
propositions que je formule il ya encore
des demi-journées disponible à
guyancourt donc on peut pas dire on va
gagner en mi-journée il suffit de
maintenir la paix mis à guyancourt et
d'augmenter le temps des permanences et
puis si les locaux ne sont pas
suffisants moi je fais des propositions
de locaux plus grands et j'indique parce
que c'est un mauvais argument que à
guyancourt justement les locaux sont
mises à disposition par la ville
la motivation pour le faire
non parce que l'année dernière mais
paris mais aussi au fc barcelone l'année
dernière chez nous voilà ça on est
capable de faire
est-ce qu'on va le faire de belle
jeunesse pourtant la donne donc l'
agence de l'environnement et de la
maîtrise de l'énergie annonce 4 %
d'économies sur la consommation lié à
l'éclair l'éclairage alors que les
opposants vous également raisonne sur la
consommation globale avec une économie
comprise entre 0 3 et 0 25%
comment on explique cette différence
m'écouter parce que l'ademe ne veut pas
prendre un temps que les études fait
dans d'autres pays en allemagne dès la
première année d'application de l'heure
d'été dans ces pays on a on a évalué des
surconsommations qui était à peu près
les deux tiers des économies d'éclairage
et cette maison de 135 mètres carrés
c'est la réalisation d'un couple
trappistes les murs de leurs habitations
font 40 cm d'épaisseur et la maison est
quasiment hermétique leur habitation
précédente
ancien énergivores a été totalement
rasée et reconstruite
il ya très peu de choix
chauffer en quasiment en totalité par le
soleil qui a un petit apport énergétique
mais qui est extrêmement minime par
rapport à une maison classique à la
route solaire ou à tous et comme l'a
nommé le groupe colas c'est
l'aboutissement de cinq ans de travaux
et de recherche ça a été fait en
partenariat avec l'insee l'institut
national de l'énergie solaire et à magny
les hameaux ses 40 mètres carrés de
route solaire qui ont été installés et
chaque panneau mesure 1 m 75 par 70 cm
philippe chevrier candidats ile de
france bleue marine aux régionales donc
dans cette région si vous deviez retenir
un des éléments de l'actualité que ce
soit en local que ce soit en national
qu'est ce qui a fait l'actualité cette
semaine pour vous aujourd'hui c'est cet
accident
malheureusement l'heure est à la
compassion mais une fois que
effectivement dans les personnes qui ont
perdu la vie une fois qu'on aura vu ça
il faudra quand même faire un retour
d'expérience parce que c'est ce qui se
passe dans le monde de l'aérien
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
en a de moins en moins d'accidents dans
l'aérien
mais dans les autres modes de transport
je vois que ça traîne un petit peu les
retours d'expérience est ce que
véritablement aujourd'hui on est sûr que
les boulons sont bien insérés sur les
voies ferrées de la sncf je voudrais en
est sûr il ya quand même des millions de
passagers kiki qui transitent en
permanence la moindre des choses c'est
qu'ils transitent en sécurité est ce que
on a résolu le problème des passages à
niveau je n'en suis pas si sûr
est-ce que sur les routes on a on parle
d'euros j'entendais ce matin qu'on
parlait de route anxiogène accidentogène
pardon et qu'est ce qu'on a fait alors
si on le savait pourquoi pourquoi on l'a
laissé voyez ce que je veux dire donc il
ya quand même la question qui se pose
derrière c'est terrible cette terrible
affaire merci nous avons accompagné
aujourd'hui pour ce journal élections
régionales 6 et 13 décembre la suite de
la campagne je vous le disais à suivre
aussi bien dans le journal que dans le
7-8 politique le mardi dès 18h30 en
attendant nous poursuivrons cette
édition ce sont à présent les enfants
qui vont réagir à l'actualité nouvelle
séquence préparé avec la participation
du collège des soldes guyancourt par
william elle pour la rédaction regarder
bonjour je m'appelle juliette je suis un
sixième est aujourd'hui je vous parlais
à des manifestations d air france donc à
la télé j'ai vu deux personnes qui se
sont fait déchirer démarche mise et qui
sont passés à travers un portail pour
effet pour éviter les salariés les
directeurs ont voulu accouche de deux
enfants ils ont voulu enlever des passes
sur le départ et que quand ils sont mus
à parler bah alors directeur hoyé au
directeur il va on leur a même pas
adressé la parole et donc à côté ça ils
sont ils se sont énervés et évasion ils
se sont déchaînés sur des personnes des
russes je trouve que c'est un peu de
lait sont pour l'efs pour ces agences
pour sa personne parce qu'ils perdent
leur travail ils perdent tout est donc
là bas ça me taxent un peu parce que la
suppression de postes sans on ne sait
pas s'ils ont une famille des enfants
c'était une famille à nourrir un
logement impayés et donc tout ça c'est
un peu dur il faut trouver un autre
travail sont au chômage puis déchiré ma
chemise je pense que la violence c'est
parce qu'ils aillent mieux enfin il faut
mieux s'expliquer que le s'explique avec
des boucs par un haut lieu de la
violence
je m'appelle noura 5e 1 et je vais
parler du 7e continent etc et dans le
continent à tout venant atlantique qui
fait six fois le tour de la france où on
a découvert qu'il y avait plein de ce à
quoi un plastique et c'est pour ça qu'on
l'appelle le septième continent il ya
plus de gens qui jettent et ça ça fait
plus de pollution
ça détruit les poissons et des fois il y
en a qui vendent des poissons et dans
les poissons il reste des petits trucs
en plastique
après ça peut nous rendre malade me et
que du coup il y aura plus de d'espèces
marines à faut éviter de jeter des trucs
en plastique même tout ce qui est tout
ce qui pollue la nature et faut faire et
c'est pour ça que l'année prochaine il y
aura plus de sacs en plastique de la
programmation de nos confrères de radio
sensations nicolas kirillovitch reçoit
pour son hebdo politique valérie
pécresse tête de liste le républicain
aux régionales en île de france 7 à 18
heures dimanche il interrogera bien sûr
sur son programme le journal revient à
lundi avec florane parfait profitez bien
de la suite de vos vacances de la
toussaint si vous en avez quelques unes
si vous disposez de quelques jours quant
à moi je vous souhaite un excellent
week-end